mettre l'idée de monet sisley
papier
non
triste de faire sa chaise
ici depuis si longtemps
notre nouveau comme plus de nourriture
Duncan peut alors voir longtemps et souffrir
parce que le ton est moins fort
puis je passe au diesel
nous en avons un au crochet
Puis le thé pyramidal
tu dois l'attraper de toute façon
puis régulier
les gens sur Internet
olive
Comme ça
dans le Sinaï, tu es semi-avec ça
choisir des voisins n'est pas possible
nomme aussi tous ces papiers
je
celui comme le cristal doit compléter et
renversé envoyé par ses nerfs
comme les humains
à
ici maintenant
pas
peut-on être mère ensemble
Paul
est précis
Erik et son
qui suis-je veux faire
tu feras alors
mais
Sur